um so welcome everybody to another
session of classic metal class uh scott
is here with me and we're discussing one
of our long time favorite bands and some
of the
recent let's call them tiffs that have
been happening in social media and
the
um
the heavy metal sphere online we're also
going to be talking a little bit about
two books um it's hard to see it here
k.k downing's heavy duty days and nights
and judas priest and rob halford's
confess
in which some of this story is being
brought out so what is what is the the
issue what is the story you could say
that you know part of it is that there's
currently two existing and i would say
rival bands that are judas priests
there's actual judas priest and then
there's kk's priest which is led by k.k
downing has tim ripper owens a former
judas priest singer with them and this
this takes us back to episode three of
this class where we talked about the
metaphysical identity of bands and
changes and you know if there's two rats
or two queens rights or two saxons which
one is the real one
um so that's one issue
but we've also got a couple other things
mixed into this it turns out it's a very
complicated situation so k.k downing uh
who's you know great uh metal guitarist
one of the founding members of judas
priest he retired from the band in 2011
and he was permanently replaced by
richie faulconer at that time and there
was some bad blood about that that we'll
talk about
and um
downing left because of significant
disagreements with management and
bandmates about epitaph but also about
other stuff as well
and
the official um story that was out is
downing is focusing on his golf course
he had this ashbury hall residence and
on building luxury residential
developments
he got into all sorts of legal messes
about this and he ended up selling the
royalty rights for 136 judas priest
songs at that time meanwhile judas
priest was supposed to be retiring
epitaph in 2000
starting in 2011 and we saw him in 2012
on that tour that was supposed to be the
final tour and it kind of made sense
because you could tell that that rob
helford
wasn't um
all that healthy he was kind of
shuffling around on stage
you know he he needed to take little
breaks during the songs to be able to
hit the high notes you could tell he was
kind of struggling
and um
shortly after that they decided nope
we're not done
we're going to record some new albums
and they you know they continued with
glenn tipton
and richie faulkner on guitar
and then tipton had to semi-retire due
to parkinson's disease and so this is
where the the story starts to get you
know really um gritty
so k.k downing
um
who you know had had a pretty strong
break with judas priests and there had
been a lot of back and forth tips within
the band before that he wants to rejoin
he in his view he should have been asked
when glenn tipton
is semi-retiring to take glenn tipton's
place
instead they bring in um
the current you know producer of judas
priest um and and uh you know a good
guitarist in his own right
and they they they bring him in uh andy
snape and
we that's what we actually saw in the
later to
2010s touring around these two younger
guys richie faulkner and andy snipe on
on guitar
um rob halford singing ian hill still
there you know grinding away on base and
k.k downing starts talking a lot of um
a lot of smack let's say right and some
of what now here's what we're going to
try to parse out some of it actually
seems to be
well
maybe he does actually have a legitimate
claim and then kk down so k.k downing is
trying to get himself into priest that's
a no-go so then he says well i'm gonna
found a new band kk's priest and he
recruits uh
tim ripper owens so you know that's part
of judas priest at one time when rob
halford's gone he recruits les banks les
banks is a judas priest uh drummer now
he'll be replaced very quickly by sean
elg and then he recruits two other guys
voodoo six bases tony newton and uh aj
mills who
is from this band called hostile who
downing was producing at the time and
downing by this time is also like sold
off his house and actually bought kk's
steel mill a place where they can play
and it's it's a you know
a music hall let's call it bar
so recently scott and i we were actually
going to do a different topic this month
um but recently there have been some
interviews with kk downing disparaging
priest's decisions saying that he ought
to be in the band saying that kk's
priest is the
next big thing there's it's kind of all
over the map the stuff that he's saying
and so i i sent this thing to scott and
i was like have you seen this and
scott's like wow there's there's a lot
going on there
and we're like well maybe we should
actually you know we like talking about
ethical issues it seems like there's
quite a few involved here
maybe we should uh
jump into this
um
and so we've been talking back and forth
about this is there anything you want to
add about this scott at this point
um because i've been talking a lot
well that's fine it's about it's been a
great history to catch us all and when
you sent me that i actually didn't
really have an idea that that was going
on um
and you know there's something and um
as far as like the notes of us chatting
what we should throw into the discussion
today is not only
um
the rights of
kk and the band and what they think but
again we keep talking about this uh the
right the audience has to
or the fans like what would what would
the fans want and does that equate into
it would would the fans love to see them
reunite
and um
and just how bad is the blood i guess is
the so you know considering like what do
you think the fans would want is that
even in the equation
well it is in part uh certainly on the
side of uh kk downing who tries to say
that you know like in a certain way he's
he's the the really authentic player for
priest and the fan favorite and you know
um what the fans would really like to
see is you know a a reunited priest
um i mean it still wouldn't be a
completely reunited place priest because
he would be playing with richie faulkner
right you know
it so there's some rhetoric involved you
could say of using the fans i don't know
i don't know that the fans really do
want to see that they're in the metal
forums
there are partisans of both sides i can
say that and there's there seem to be a
lot of people who are pissed off at um
kk downing
for constantly sniping that priest and
and also saying i want to be in there
um chris says heads are going to roll
yeah
and it's interesting because i in doing
the research for this i you know i was
looking at some other things and kk
downing um
there was like a list of what he thinks
are the ten best you know judas priest
songs and he he said that's one of them
um
but
the other thing with that you know
so that was often the heaviest album
that that priest i i want to say that
defenders of the faith is actually
heavier than than painkiller um just
because of the way it's done now that's
debatable we talked about that's
debatable yeah painkiller's pretty
pretty happening it is yeah yeah but um
that's one of the heaviest songs off of
that heaviest of albums and k.k downing
has been positioning himself as being
like you know the authentic
uh
going back to you know the real
pre-sound he's been kind of using that
idea
um that he was involved in the moving
away from the pragee stuff to
to the uh
more bare bones heavy metal and so i
think that's that's part of the picture
um
yeah so the audience thing though um i
guess we'd we'd have to like do
surveying or
yeah i mean the forums is is a clever
thing to check out what people are
saying i just want to
interject here something really
interesting as far as generations go um
my students at berkeley
they're big priest fans the metal guys
but they're everybody's number one album
is painkiller like everybody's that's
that's making sense
you know they're like you know and you
know i've had four students in the last
few years do that solo from that song
as their proficiency piece and that's
you know if you're a priest fan that's
the soul you've got to tackle like it's
interesting
because when we came up you know all the
other albums were coming up while we
were you know in high school or in
junior high and so we saw these in real
time so it's great to see somebody
looking way back at the catalog and they
all jumped a painkiller yeah
um you know these students are wearing
pre-shirts in in school like the metal
heads you know iron maiden and priest
are like the two and sabbath although i
guess there's a three but
but yeah that's that's kind of like my
two cents for what i've observed the
people that are ages 18 to 21 right now
when we when we did that episode on the
top five albums of
it's like key bands like judas priest
iron maiden uh motorhead dio
it was split between if i remember right
painkiller and screaming for vengeance
wasn't it yeah my vote was screened for
vengeance yeah and i i was an outlier
with sin after said that's a great one
though i mean i mean
yeah we could actually talk about like
different periods like there's the
early
you know first three albums
moving into staying class right where
they're they're sort of formulating
their sound there is a lot of praggy
stuff going on then there's the we could
call it the um classic judas priest
thing ev everything from stained glass
up to defenders of the faith
then we have this you know kind of
weirdo what what's going on here turbo
uh ram it down
and then painkiller comes on top of that
and painkiller is like a return to form
except now incorporating new drumming
techniques and stuff like that and that
you know that amazing
vocal performance when you see helpful
doing it in concert it is like an
athletic event you know yeah and then
you know you get the albums after that
where they're they're kind of meandering
a little bit but as as uh
chris points out firepower the recent
priest album is really good
um and that's that's interesting because
so we should talk a little bit about um
priest songwriting i think that'll be
helpful in seeing where kk downing is
coming from
so
early on
judas priest actually has a kind of
similar history in its very beginning to
the scorpions where
none of the people
who
are currently listed as like original
members of judas priest are actually
original members of the original judas
priest
there there was a band called judas
priest fronted by al atkins who was
their their singer and kk downing and
ian hill and a couple other people were
playing together and that original judas
priest broke up just like the original
scorpions broke up
and then atkins um
and a couple others come over and
they're like uh you know let's uh put
together a band and they're chit
chatting about it now in his book um k.k
downing says that it was his idea
because he he really loved that that
name judas priest to say well why don't
we call this new band judas priest
and that's what they did so the the band
that forms with ian hill and with kk
downing and al atkins and a few other
people that's the
sort of second judas priest just like
with the scorpions riddle schechner
leaves the original band which breaks up
he joins another band he's the only guy
coming in and he says let's use this
name scorpions so judas priest had some
currency
and then um
you know al atkins i think this is kind
of a famous story that a lot of people
know
um it's sort of like the paul diano uh
bruce dickinson thing except that you
know al atkins wasn't forced out he quit
he's like we're not making enough money
i got a wife and kids
see you later i can't do this and then
that's when they recruit rob helford
um and
one thing i think you can say about
drummers and judas priests is drummers
are important but they they're sort of
like ac dc they never really hold on to
the same drummer all that long
as opposed to guitarists and stuff like
that so now you got a four piece set and
they're about to head into making their
first album rock-a-rolla
and
the management says
you know maybe you should fill out the
sound with another guitar
so they bring in glenn tipton
and he's viewed he i mean he's always
positioned by kk downing in his book
oops who as as being sort of like you
know a bit of an outsider
and you know he wasn't the original
guitarist and he also tries to take over
and stuff like that and some of that
might be true and some of that might
might not be true there's an awful lot
of sniping going on in kk downing's
heavy duty days and night days and
nights in judah's priest at
glen tipton
and so they they record the album and
now they're judas priest right they have
two guitarists they have uh ian hill
they have rob halford
and they're they're you know going
around and doing all their their sort of
stuff now who's writing the songs
rob helford is writing the lyrics makes
perfect sense since he's the singer
he's also doing a lot of the melodies
because he's an incredible vocal talent
the rest of the songwriting is credited
to the two guitarists glenn tipton and
k.k downing and apparently there was bad
blood
early on because
k.k downing felt that you know um
or yeah that tipton was was trying to
like
crimp his style
and not let him solo enough in
comparison to to uh um glenn tipton but
those are the three main people writing
ian hill is contributing stuff but he's
not getting credited and the drummers
are basically just drumming you know um
getting replaced every so often
um sort of like you know um i don't know
the drummers are sort of like a spare
tire or something you could say
now
once
kk downing leaves
who is doing the songwriting is it just
um
rob halford and
glenn tipton no richie faulkner
is assuming a absolutely central role
and that's why the priest albums after
that epitaph tour like firepower
sound the way that they do
so you know you could think about well
what would it be like if it was k.k
downing and richie faulkner and um
uh
uh not ian hill um rob halford you know
doing it in the present and we're never
going to find that out because you know
k.k downing isn't being asked back and
glenn tipton is still writing for judas
priest
even though he's not touring because he
has parkinson's disease he is still
an integral part of the writing process
so this is i think very important back
uh story
because a lot of you know a lot of the
charges being made have to do with who's
doing the writing and who gets credited
and you know who's determining which
direction priest is going
glenn tipton has a tendency to say that
like everything that went wrong in the
directions that priests took that's the
other guys especially
i mean k.k downing has says it's them
especially you know uh rob halford and
glenn tipton um
he doesn't i don't see an awful lot of
him saying yeah i screwed up here
well that's you know and that's that's
interesting
um that that doesn't strengthen his
argument that's maybe while we're a
little well maybe that's true maybe it's
not true yeah since it shows no
accountability is uh
now you bring up something really
interesting
does kk downing have ann a single
argument or
is he just like
reacting to things and doing the
proverbial throw [ __ ] at the wall and
see what sticks
or is it something in between in your
view if there is a single argument i
would love to hear what it is because i
look at all the things that he's saying
right and i'm a little bit confused
well you know i
i mean
there's things i guess i would focus in
on like okay he's certainly an original
member
um yeah his one point about
you know he didn't do the farewell tour
in that article he said right no no yeah
he he quit before that he quit before
that so
and you know he kind of has a good point
because the band didn't end up going
into retirement
you know so maybe he would have you know
uh
they asked him to do it he didn't want
to do it so um i think that's right they
gave him a crack out but he just he quit
he didn't want to do it he according to
him he wanted to do what originally
became the playlist for the epitaph tour
like a chronological thing which was
amazing to see by the way sure because
you know he had rob halford up on stage
sort of explaining and then we did this
and then we did this and here's where we
transitioned this way and by the way you
might like this or you might not like
this you know here's turbo
um
yeah he wanted according to him that's
what he wanted to do
um the band's management wanted them to
do a um an ep
uh rather than an lp before the tour
right that's a terrible idea yeah
um but it seems like a lot of the
friction was already going on before
that and that was sort of like the straw
that broke the camel's back kind of
thing
yeah i mean i just feel like uh you make
a great point that he's very scattered
and i do get this idea he's gonna throw
everything
against the wall to see what sticks but
you you mentioned really in passing
something really interesting
that you know like you know my version
of priest is going to be the next big
thing it's like well wait a minute
do you want your
if your band's going to be the next big
thing why do you want back with priest
yeah there seems to be a contradiction
there right
yeah i think i think
i think you've kind of nailed it from my
perspective as far as
reading just the article you sent and
then you know like a lot of the stuff
you told me about the book
um it seems reactionary it's kind of
like maybe it was
only at the beginning he said i went
back in and they said no and then it
just turns into
complete reaction
which
which i don't think is helping his case
i don't know what you think it's just
so that's that's interesting because we
could compare it to somebody else um
who's you know
very famously exited a band actually two
interesting people who exited bands and
then it turned out to be a really great
thing
um so
the earliest one that i'm thinking about
is um lemmy getting kicked out of
hawkwind right let me write really
integral to hawkman he actually switched
from playing guitar to playing bass and
that's where he kind of formed his
bass consciousness you could say and
those albums that he's on it's really
he's really central to it and i guess he
was kind of an important part of the
stage presence then he gets kicked out
on the tour he doesn't really fit into
hawkwind you could say in terms of like
look at ethos and all that and then he
goes on for motorhead and you know
wow awesome that he did that right
another case where maybe resentment
played a i mean it's not clear that
lemmy was all that resentful he's like
oh i'm gonna like you know show them up
but somebody who definitely was gonna
show them up dave mustaine
oh right that's a classic one yeah and
again
great that he did because right
i mean i'm going to lay my cards on the
table here if you were to ask me before
cliff burton died which is the better
thrash band metallica or mega death i
would have said well it's close but i
would say metallica
and if you were to ask me you know four
years later which is the the next which
is the best one i would say mega death
yeah i agree i i you know um there was
something
to cliff's
contra contribution as far as um
attitude
yeah and you know i think that one of
the things i wonder a lot is when people
die early or young
you know well they were just getting
started with their voice and craft so it
would have been interesting to hear what
metallica would have continued on
because he was
he was very important to their sound and
we've talked about this in the past and
i think the band dynamics as well um
i
i think i mean it's very clear that the
that jason newstead was treated like
sort of a second class citizen by ulric
and hetfield i know i know we're getting
in the weeds a little bit here but i
think we can we can bring this back and
talk about priest and you know tim
ripper owens and how he was treated
maybe um which doesn't seem to be that
great you know and this sort of thing
goes on in bands you know um ian gillen
talks about this in deep purple that
that he felt that he was never really
treated like a full member of the band
because he wasn't an original member of
the band you know
um so jason newstead coming in he he
couldn't present the sort of like hold
on guys uh do we really want to go in
that direction that that cliff burton
could
you know
well this is this is important to talk
about because this is part of
you know
we're talking about people's role in the
band and we
you know
we're drawing comparisons to these other
people and
we could bring it back to kk about
how what he contributed well the
songwriting you know i'd like to know
like for example who came up which one
of them came up with the heads are gonna
roll riff that intro riff which is so
iconic yeah um that that intro i
remember the first time i heard that
when the album came out
it just i i it was in my head all day
and they didn't announce who the band
was but it ended up being on the radio
yeah
and um i wonder who wrote that riff
because you know some of the riffs are
fantastic was it all kk was it did they
you know i don't know so i mean what i
get
and this is mostly coming from downing's
book heavy duty days and nights in judas
priest is
that
he and i mean they would have these
sessions right and play together
and
so obviously the drama and the bassist
are still part of that that process as
well
and they would do a lot of you know
you know noodling and playing around
with riffs and putting things together
and kk talks much more about the solos
than he does about the riffs
because he's really pissed off about
glenn tipton according to kk downing
um
hogging the spotlight
shortening the solos that that downing
was supposed to do or giving giving
downing less solos and and you could say
how did he give you less i mean weren't
you there in the room you know and and
his presentation i mean he says it over
and over again in the book it's like you
know downing just had a way of getting
people to
uh well here so here's here's a good
example right
um
it had become apparent that because i
generously let glenn in on the first
album most of which al atkins and i had
written the song writing was eventually
going to become a three-way split among
rob glenn and i
i just thought that if we agreed to
evenly split the songwriting duties that
would in turn guarantee the financial
side of things going forward nobody
could argue with that logic it meant
that hopefully the best ideas would
always rise to the top i just didn't
want weaknesses to start creeping in
and then he says
however now this is
a long time ago on sad wings of destiny
i started to find myself in a position
where i'd be coming to the table with
what i thought were solid ideas only to
have them rejected and replaced with
something of glenn's instead
at the time i thought i'm totally pissed
off with this at the time what i
actually said was okay then
and here he has something quite quite
interesting
this is talking about
sin after sin
speaking of weaknesses i thought last
rose of summer was exactly that
well we love that song i know and when
you read rob halford's book you get a
very different uh it's not showing up on
here you get a very different take on
that right this is halford and with that
and raw deal this is hellford coming out
to his bandmates
yeah
and uh
yeah he says um
it seem it felt to me that glenn and rob
were on the queen ban bandwagon so glenn
had this idea to compose a ballad type
song on the piano knowing full well if
he could carve out something to take to
rob
rob would probably jump on it because
ballads often appeal to singers
and
he also didn't like them doing uh
diamonds and rust
you know
so there so i think there's i mean
there's definitely like divergences in
the musical sensibilities going on right
now to what degree
was it um glenn tipton really
steamrollering and you know
machiavellian manipulation of the band
to get his stuff forward and downplay
kks i mean
that's tough to tell right
we weren't there you weren't there yeah
and you don't see anything like that
happening in rob helford's account
and
ian hill has never said anything like
that so
i'm inclined to
to view it as hyperbole
yeah
yeah i mean it's so interesting that
those songs were uh
picked out because we when we did that
show we talked about
we talked about that ballad and we all
really thought it was fantastic and um
so he thought that was a mistake
well
i mean um
i don't know
i mean that that is that usually
that's what happened like with the
go-go's their first album what's her
name jane wheeldon it was a jane no it
was
it was one of the guitars wrote all the
songs and so she got rich
and the other people and then
the next album they're like you're only
allowed one song to write because we're
gonna write and make some money
and her song was vacation which went
number one and so so but what van halen
did was they put everybody down so
everybody got paid i mean i do agree
with that you know so there's not
financial resentment
so um you could still have resentment
about your musical ideas not being
that's right paid attention to i mean i
think the dominant theme of kk's musical
ideas is i want things to sound more
like breaking the law or
uh hellbent for leather or
[Music]
the sentinel he's actually got a song
referencing the sentinel on his new
album you know um so i think he he
really favored the heavy side and he
didn't like the
more more either progy or or ballady
sort of stuff
um so i i would imagine although he
doesn't say this that if you think about
hell i'm not hellbound for leather
screaming for vengeance you think about
the song fever which i think is an
amazing song on there but it's a ballad
i don't i think he probably didn't like
that as much you know
that's interesting well yeah i mean
when the band's going in a different
direction
yeah
well and this is another thing that
you know we still haven't jumped into
all the ethical issues but maybe this is
this is something good to think about
would priests catalogue be
strengthened or weakened
by having a let's call it a still a wide
but a narrower heavy metal like this is
all clearly identifiable as heavy metal
kind of sound or are they better off
having
um
songs where
you know there's more there's more
playing around with it like think about
the first part of the rage right it
starts out with that awesome bass solo
it's kind of slow-moving or dying to
meet you you know
also starts out with a great baseline
and it's kind of soft at the beginning
and then it goes into you know the the
heavier stuff later or diamonds and rust
or
right um off of you know one of the
things that people complained about
believe it or not on defenders of the
faith is when night comes down people
are like this doesn't sound like a
jewish priest song you know
and you're like well okay maybe
maybe it doesn't sound like a usual
judas priest song it's not breaking the
law
but it's still a great song and it fills
out
it fills out the um
what would you call it it doesn't just
fill out a catalog a catalog is just a
listing it fills out the
musical space of the band um
you know
yeah no i yeah i mean it's kind of
if you put an album on there's got
what's it's like picking a set list even
if you're a metal band
it can't be here the whole time right
yeah yeah no um i mean i suppose with
thrash bands maybe but you know an
audience needs this kind of thing where
you know
and an album i think in the same way
you know for it to all be breaking the
laws
i mean i you know
i don't know i just uh
maybe that's one of the things that made
them great is is it wasn't the same
uh
i don't agree with that oh this is an
interesting point that mark is making
what do you think of this scott priest
wouldn't be priest without downing
and it wouldn't be priest if it was only
downing
well that's what we're talking about
right so
you know judas priest kk down he's judas
priest we're not going to call that
judas priest really right
i think this is more about the
the writing up until 2011.
mark is saying something like
judas priest really wouldn't be the
judas priest sound without kk downing in
those
important formative years i think that's
probably right i agree um but it
wouldn't be priest if if if downing like
dominated the songwriting process
well that's true because you know you're
missing um
glenn well is glenn writing still you
said yeah so
um and who knows you know
you know uh
people write
in different eras you know uh kind of
like when somebody's like why didn't why
isn't robert plant doing led zeppelin
stuff well because he's in a different
part of his life and he wouldn't be
writing
you know
uh he wouldn't be writing early zeppelin
stuff because he's not a
an 18 year old in the 16th no you know
um so it's time and place as well
you know um
and priest is still iconic i mean
halford and
you know you and i saw him a few years
ago and it was unbelievable yeah you
know
um
i have to say too that
watching them on stage
i've gotten to see them
both with glenn tipton and richie
faulkner right so right old classic
guitarist new new guy on the scene
and also with the two young guys richie
faulkner and andy snead
and
i thought they did a great job and
you know they they they do kind of i
mean richie faulconer is not just a uh
kk downing clone although kk down
accused him of being such um he really
did yeah when he when he first got hired
and um that's sour grapes that's i'm
sorry that's just
yeah
oh wow okay going i didn't mean to
interrupt that no no i and i thought
they did it it was really
it made sense it was identifiably judas
priest um i think
that these are these are musicians who
came up on priest um there's a 30-year
difference between
richie faulconer and um um kk downing
but maybe that's enough to actually like
help in a way you know it it maybe it's
better to bring in somebody who's been
you know
nourished on on that stuff and can step
in rather than somebody who's closer in
time you know well that's true and i
think you know i was really really
impressed with with richie live like
when i got to see him he's a great
performer he looks cool he looks like he
doesn't look out of place he's you know
and his plane's great i do i do take
you know um
you know kk taking a shot at this guy
um in any way is is just inappropriate
that's not professional that's uh
that sounds like bitterness that sounds
like i mean it's just spite at that
point right he's angry so he's gonna
well i mean on the one hand so it it's
clear that there were things
that we weren't being told about the
2011 the downing departure right
and it looks like he had a lot of
resentments
going back a long ways and we don't we
don't really know
what
what's true in this this account maybe
maybe uh he was pushed to the side in
some of the songwriting stuff
and maybe he has some legitimate beefs
but he didn't handle them well
um i mean if you look at richie faulkner
and k.k downing you could see how
somebody who is kk downing could say
what the hell man they just got this guy
who plays with a similar guitar to me
and has a similar look and what's what's
going on here
i mean
i know but it's not um
i mean the poor you know uh the poor guy
replaced it i mean he doesn't mean
disrespect to kkk he's got his dream gig
yeah yeah he'll be raised on that and um
i i unders i kind of understand that but
um that's besides the point because
uh
these you'd have to have to be replaced
by somebody because he quit
yeah you know so it's interesting too so
we still haven't gotten into a lot of
the ethical issues that we wanted to
explore we've been kind of noodling
around you might say but since we're
talking about richie faulconer
his his contribution to the like stuff
out there in the media has been to say
you guys really need to put this feud
behind you you know so here's an example
this is from classic rock richie
faulconer urges kk downing and judas
priest to end their [ __ ] show feud
right uh and this this is summarizing a
different interview that was done he
says uh the whole situation with him and
the band over the last 10 years to me
has been totally unnecessary it's been a
bit of a [ __ ] show and i don't know why
that is to me
music aside they should maybe pick up
the phone just talk to each other's
buddies and go and have a beer and just
be pales you know screw music for a
minute let's just be pals and then
whatever happens happens they were pals
for 40 years they lived pretty much
together for 40 years four decades
and then he says i wish it was different
all that weirdness of the last 10 years
didn't need to happen if they parted on
good terms maybe things would be
different now but unfortunately that
that didn't happen and i think that's
you know
smart take you know yeah
no yeah that is i mean
you're talking about somebody that's
involved with the project but wasn't
involved with the drama per se like you
know he doesn't have a beef with anybody
you could say he he was a pretext for
drama
but not not instigating the drama well
if it wasn't him it would be someone
else i mean it's he him just you know
somebody had to be hired when kk quit i
mean that's it you know so if it wasn't
him it would be someone else unless
unless judas priest had toured as a four
piece and this is an additional part of
the drama
so
judas priests floated the idea of being
a
a quartet and it turns out that rob
halford actually said well this is my
idea
another funny interview i read about it
biff byford of saxon was asked about
this and he said i think they must have
been drunk at the time when they made
this decision because how are you
actually going to do judas priest as a
four piece and richie faulconer said you
know i think i could probably pull it
off
it's going to take some like rethinking
how to do this but i i i guess i could
do it and then you know the question
that you got to ask is well
why
why shut out this guy
andy snead
who has you know produced their latest
albums like firepower who knows their
whole catalog who's a good guitarist um
and the idea i think was to create more
space for glenn tipton to like you know
show up on on stage every once in a
while but that that's not a good
reasoning for it and then judas priest
actually reversed their decision to
remove uh andy snape from the live
lineup now they're they're gonna tour as
a five piece k.k downing could not
resist the opportunity
to to complain about this
he said you know
a four-piece judas priest is a slap in
the face that's the the title of uh
one interview
and now here's where we get to this
inconsistency thing again
so i'm going to read a little bit of
this former judas priest guitarist kk
downing considers it insulting that his
former band mates even briefly
considered touring with a four-piece
lineup
um
[Music]
like he says i'm like everybody else i'm
totally bemused it was so extreme and
insulting in a way i guess and insulting
to glenn as well it was kind of a slap
in the face saying okay you two guys did
it but we think one just one guy can do
it it kind of made us and everything
we've done and created seems superfluous
really i'm sure glenn will agree with me
that it does have a value there must be
something behind the scenes that we
don't know so this to me seems like like
crap stirring you know
um if he if he thinks that you know
glenn tipton's ideas aren't really that
valuable why is he bringing him in as a
and trying to put words in his mouth
it seems like
this created an opportunity for kk
downing to have something yet again bad
to say about about priests and it might
be just opportunistic he might be well
i've got this new band we need some
publicity this will bring it you know
well that's you know that's true because
as you said that you've seen on the
boards there's been kind of a split
yeah like you know their team kk or
their team priest or
um
but yeah i mean i i guess at this point
i'm confused uh because
if he wanted back in the band talking
smack about the band non-stop is not
going to help help win the band it's a
strange strategy right
maybe some a new strategy we don't know
about but um yeah i'm you know with all
the complaining and is he trying to make
his band the next big thing i mean good
luck
i mean you know without halford it's
what's kind of like when iron maiden
who's the guy um
blaze uh
bailey i think yeah yeah and so that was
a tough sell because they also had
they also had yannick
as the new guitarist then so oh
replacing adrian smith yeah adrian left
and um that was those were tough that
was a tough sell so
um
we talked a bit about key players yeah
you know and you know you can't have
iron maiden without uh steve harris you
can't i mean that would just uh but you
know can you have priests without kkk i
mean it's a classic lineup we grew up
with it and
we dig it of course in a perfect world
that would be the band
but you know things come up but
um
you know that's actually a really great
point uh in a perfect world yeah all of
these bands that we loved at a
particular time would retain exactly the
same players and they just keep turning
out music that sounds like that
and there's two things that we're kind
of missing in that one is that all of
these guys are getting older
just as we are and so
there is no way to like hold together i
mean think about the scorpions right so
the scorpions still have a fairly
classic lineup with klaus miner
rudy schenker
i mean they don't have they don't have
their original drummer
um i think francis bucholtz is he still
with them or did he quit as their
bassist
uh i don't know i'm not sure the current
lineup matias is flynn yeah i mean
matthias jobs is he's not the original
guitarist but neither was he levan roth
and so he's been with him long enough
that i think we can say there's a stable
lineup but i mean how long can that last
those guys are
getting pretty old we can't expect that
they are somehow just going to like say
well i'm never going to retire the fans
get to decide this kind of goes to that
that like thing that you're talking
about the
it's not a contract it's like a set of
assumptions between
uh fans and audience and the musicians
themselves and we also ignore the fact
that maybe the musicians
do in fact want to leave maybe you know
kk downing
he gets to say i'm going to take off i
mean he points out that rob halford you
know decided to leave the band for a
while
yeah and do his own things right and he
says
now this is kind of a legitimate point
that swings us back into the ethical
questions
k.k downing one of the key things that
he says that i think we really should
consider
so you were willing to
let rob helford leave the band and then
come back when he asked to do so
why the hell aren't you doing that for
me that's actually that's now that's a
good point
that's a really so you think there's
something to that i mean you know but
the problem is he dilutes it with all
the other stuff okay if he pick
if he were to pick and choose good
points
okay that's an yeah that's so that's a
great point i think uh i think if you're
on one hand making a good point and then
you say something
um
malicious or you see you know uh you
complain um that under i just i just
feel like especially when you set that
article i just feel like he was he
he was undermining his own arguments he
has some legitimate things i mean so
he's really making too many arguments
right
yeah but in like you said it's kind of
all over the place like you know go back
to the throw in the spaghetti the wall
and something else you know
but you know that's actually a really
good point so when halford want to come
back
that was good
um and yeah i mean
if you were to stick to points like that
they do make sense
um
you know and you know being one of the
writers um so he's obviously has an
important role in the sound
um of the priest sound you know and um
of course his plane you know you would
recognize his plane
um
but i just you know
that's an that's an interesting ethical
point it's kind of i don't know all that
you know um here's here's a great uh
point by by mark um
we'll come back to other ethical
arguments and points but going back to
the
thing that we were just talking about
with um you know is it reasonable for us
the fans to expect the band to remain
the same i sometimes wonder if part of
the problem and this is something you've
touched on a lot before in the past
scott isn't that most of these guys
never expected to do this whole rock
star thing for so long lots of issues
have cropped up that are kind of
unprecedented within the heavy metal
world how do a good question so i want
to hear your take on this how do other
music professionals outside of metal
handle aging in their career how do they
adjust their lives to accommodate these
changes
that's a really great point um
so i think part of the thing that we've
talked about before is you take a band
like
priest
and there's not a lot of people that
like you know i i brought up robert
plant that completely sounds
different now but yeah and people like
why aren't you doing this episode
because i can't and that's an
interesting thing so
um i've gone through my own phases where
in my twenties i would just play any gig
i didn't care what it was like in a van
with no heat
and um and then as i got older i said
well maybe i should be a little more
selective did you ever you ever play in
like a cage like the blues brothers
where they throw the bottles and stuff
um
no actually i didn't but i played a lot
of interesting stuff i related
being at the wrong bar you know
um
so
i think
mark you rate raise a great point
because i have the luxury of like waking
up one day and going
i'm not gonna play corporate events
anymore because you know the corporate
defense events play really and pay
really well but you're treated like dirt
and it's you know and it's too much
drama and it sucks your soul and
i want to do this now and then i'm
deciding to compose differently whatever
however if you're in like a band like
priest
yeah where there's where there's a logo
and a history and yeah and you don't
you know uh
you know you say you don't
it's not in you anymore like when you
were 20. or
yeah and like a lot of fans they ask
it's like you know we thought this could
be a five-year run we didn't know we'd
be doing this for 40 years or whatever
yeah you know and like look at the
rolling stones
it's like you know did they they must
still enjoy it because they still tour
and i'm sure they have enough money but
um
i have a certain luxury
in my music career to change as i age
and um
but you know i don't have a
crazy fan base like
priest and
you know they're expected to go out kill
a show and
um the aging thing you know it's like
well maybe they can't do the road as
long you know where
i remember when bon jovi's sliver and
wet wet came out they like when they
tour that for two years it was such a
big album
and um by the time i saw bon jovi on
that tour like john had no voice left
and um
so i think that's a really cool thing
because we become different people um
and maybe people within the band are uh
growing into different people and
they're not it's not the same family
that it was when
it was the 80s you know um
and you know that you know maybe they
didn't assume that these kind of
problems would ever come up they didn't
think about this when the
first few albums came out or whatever
they didn't think
um
[Music]
they didn't have to deal with stuff it's
like any relationship i guess um
you know you test a relationship with
somebody goes through a hard time or
whatever and how how the relationship
responds to that and i guess the
age and maturity and everything has to
all play into it but they don't have
the luxury uh so i could
you know well some people have to um you
know they'll say i you know i don't want
to do the road anymore i want to stay
home with my family but then they're out
well you know and that was something
that was a bone of contention with uh
um kk downing and glenn tipton
um glenn tipton got married to one of
the managers and and oh
you know they they had like a home life
together and this comes up uh in in the
somewhere in the 80s
in uh
tipton's book and he says
um
you know we were like why aren't we
going on the road and and glenn tipton
was the obstacle to that according to to
kk downing again
not not quite sure how true that is you
know seems like there were other
other issues within the band as well
um i mean it's interesting too because
ian hill
are you know another one of the early
members are ostensibly an original
member who's never left the band
you know like a good bassist has been
like the rock that that has held things
together
and um
he and glenn tipton you know knew each
other actually before they got in the
band
and um
ian hill's also was was married to rob
halford's sister for for some time and
and you know
downing is also mad at
um ian hill in part because ian hill has
said listen we're not we're not changing
the lineup
um
he ruled out um
downing joining priest on their on their
50-year tour saying
i don't know where he was coming from
with that comment i think he just played
a bit of mischief to be honest i mean
ken's place in the band has already been
taken he's sitting right there you know
he points at faulkner it's also two
albums down the road since nostradamus
which is the last one he played on
is he gonna be prepared to play music
from the new album you know which he
probably would not and on top of that
he's gonna have to learn glenn's parts
too
so it's all reasons why we didn't ask
him to return apart from that he's been
retired for nearly eight years so this
is this strikes me as very reasonable
it's you know he's saying
don't worry about who was an original
member
or you know who's who got to leave and
come back there's some real
practicalities here you know
you don't like len tipton and yet you'd
be playing his parts because richie
faulconer is now playing your parts
and
you didn't you didn't play on the
firepower album so you're gonna you're
gonna learn i mean actually scott let me
ask you
as a musician who has done a lot of
studio and gigging work
how hard would it be
to like
learn um the whole judas priest
firepower album
riff by riff lick by lick
solo by solo so that you could go out on
the road and do it you know um
for 40 shows
i don't you know
i'll say for me
um i would probably need
10 days to have a completely memorized
and learned
uh to show up to rehearse it okay and
then
um if we're going to do the whole album
i mean
that's ten days just focusing on that
task
yeah like so let's say i've never heard
the album okay and then somebody gives
it gives it to me i'd really go through
it meticulously first i'd listen to it
listen to it and then i transcribe the
parts the tough the longest bit would be
memorizing it for me
um
so but i don't know what set of skills
kk actually has though like um that's
been his career has been playing his own
music
and um my career has been
learning
uh
entire sets for artists or rock bands as
a side musician on stage like i talked
about um
i was called on a thursday
at 3 p.m
a few years ago to sub for skunk baxter
uh you know from the doobie brothers and
steely dan
and the
very good dro from the band boston was
in there the drummer from james brown so
they said they gave me four steely dan
tunes to learn and memorize four boston
tunes to learn to memorize for
james brown and four um
uh bob marley tunes and then
brother songs so 18 songs total yeah and
you know steely dan's not the easiest
stuff um plus i wanted to learn skunk
baxter's solo's note for note out of
respect to him
and
i did that in under 12 hours i mean i
had to pull all nighter in the hotel
i had to be ready for sound check next
at 11 but that's just that's just a
skill you gain when you practice ear
training when you practice
and but you know no disrespect to kk but
that is his his
life uh his his position as a musician
was never
that working musician thing it was
always you know we're going to get
together we're going to write this album
so you know it is a question whether
he'd be capable you know depending on
how
difficult the guitar solos are
you know or how difficult
or if how he is at lifting songs off
albums so i i can't speak for him but
yeah i mean it seems perfectly
reasonable that he could
you know um it might be a longer
learning curve than like like it might
be a longer learning curve yeah um but
you know i always you know if it's going
to be something
involved and i've never heard it it's
good the memorization part is going to
be the the hard part so he'd have to you
know listen to the album a lot he'd have
to
whatever he'd have to do i mean i think
he could do it but i think the most
uncomfortable part of what you just said
was
he'd be playing glenn tipton's parts
although could we couldn't he go back to
being kk and making richie do the glen
tipton parts i wonder i mean it sounds
like richie faulconer probably could do
that but here's here's we actually this
is a great jumping off point right so
rob has his finger right on things
it seems like kk thinks he has some sort
of right to come back that he's being
denied what sort of thing might ground
such a right are there other sorts of
associations or groups that might be a
useful
analogy
and
you know
being able to step back into your old
shoes as if you hadn't left 10 years
before
that's that's a big ask and and i think
that kk downing does view himself as
entitled in some way to this so this is
something we should talk about we've
we've talked about the hey rob halford
got to do it why can't i do it and
you know you could say well
you know
they don't they don't sing the the
ripper owens stuff right as a matter of
fact there's a true there's a tiff going
on right now about whether
um they're even going to have that stuff
available on apple music or not um
wow so it's not quite the same
i i think another thing that that tipton
keeps bringing up that he must think
entitles him to it is i was one of the
original members you know um
[Music]
uh ian hill and me are the only original
members of judas priest left
you know rob helford came in later glenn
tipton came in later the many drummers
have come and gone i'm not even going to
talk about them so therefore i have a
greater claim because
i was you know
there at the beginning and i mean it
would be it'd be kind of weird right
because it would be sort of like
if gary moore had said that about thin
lizzy you know get rid of these these
guys you know scott gorham and brian
roberts said i want to come back you
know that's an interesting point
uh because they had a lot of you know
john sykes was in thin lizzy right right
oh that's an interesting point um
yeah
doesn't does does being part of the
original configuration give you greater
greater rights in some way or entitle
you to consideration that other people
wouldn't have i mean i think so i mean i
i guess i mean it doesn't mean it's a
hard yes it just means
you know that's
that would be part of his good argument
let's i mean let's follow that logic out
with some other bands so if um
if michael schechner quit being a jerk
to his older brother
and saying disparaging things about him
and said i want to rejoin the scorpions
um you should
you know
send
you know maybe maybe we'll also keep uh
mattias jobs or maybe mattias jobs needs
to retire i should i should get to do
that
would we would we
give him any
you know
would we say that's plausible at all i
don't think so
was michael even an original member
though yeah won't unload some crow
oh okay yeah you're probably right or
was or was he maybe i'm wrong about that
um because there was uh uh
well he got stolen away from the
scorpions by ufo
right
that's right yeah that's right that's
right um but it's very early on in the
band's
trajectory you know right
i'm trying to think i mean
that that almost
that's the
important thing
here's a good example when iron maiden
when when bruce dickinson left iron
maiden
um if paul diana had said hey guys i'm
ready to patch it up you bring me back i
don't think the rest of the band i mean
steve harris definitely wouldn't have
said
yeah welcome back great to have you as
the original singer instead they got
blaise bailey right
so that's that's a great point although
the thing that happened with iron maiden
is
when they got bruce dickinson
they really took off and you know most
fans
it's actually starts with bruce
dickinson which is uh but you know it's
interesting a lot of the people
if you take um take
take iron maiden when adrian smith was
ready to come back
they kept
yawns
yeah
yannick rather they kept ionic so it's a
three guitar band i thought that was
silly but i think that was probably good
you know it was probably an ethical
thing to do since you know yannick put
his hours in and i remember
well
then what if we apply that to tim ripper
owens
you know i mean
he could have been a backup singer or
something instead they're like well rob
is in you're out see you later
yeah there's only room for one front man
but yeah and i don't know if you um i
know it's not metal but
um if you know anything about ario
speedwagon the original guitar is gary
was kicked out in 89 just because he
couldn't
he just went off of the deep end with
drugs and drinking oh okay and so if you
ever saw him behind the music
you know the whole time gary's like i
want to be back in the band you know and
i want to be you know whatever and
they would go back and forth a
confessional and they said well
you know if he can clean up
we'll sit down with dave amato who
replaced him and they would have been a
two guitar ario speedwagon okay and so
like i always thought that was
interesting it's like you know you can't
just
it's not nice to like hire someone bring
them in the band they write a bunch of
albums go hey the original guy wants to
come back you got to leave now yeah i
mean there is something so they they
they always with guitars to talk about
adding on like maybe it would be a third
guitarist and which might be silly but
maiden did it yeah
so chris brings up chris squire yes i
mean what do you think about that
chris squire but he's dead now
well so yeah he can't rejoin anything
you can enjoy the bands in the sky
right um
chris squire wow
miss him i mean
if you think about how many musicians
have died this is a total side note and
imagine that they all go to some place
whether heaven or hell or you know
musician valhalla
imagine some of the and they have
equipment imagine some of the sessions
that would be
going on down there you know like you
could have uh lemmy playing with theo
you know jimi hendrix and pick a whole
bunch of people
the best gigs happening right now
we might have mozart composing for metal
bands
yeah
so mark uh mark and chris both have uh
uh oh so he's saying about chris choir
veto over yes members
mark also says if downing is a founder
of priests i guess his claim to
legitimacy might depend on so this is a
good point the extent to which priests
adhered to and flourished under his
founding vision
i mean
i don't know that we can say that he had
a founding vision it would be sort of
like
uh his dimension of the founding sound
of of priests right
um
but yeah what was
what did you want to say about the the
chris squire part
oh that i i misinterpreted uh v to over
yes members got it chris yeah oh no i
was going to say um
something to mark's point while you were
talking uh
i forgot his role in the the judas
priest sound you know and ethos
um well i was gonna make the point that
you
what you just read that halford said
something that i didn't address
um
did kk down well i guess he's he's been
busy with his other projects so he's
kept his playing up
yeah he he hasn't he's he's also played
at festivals and things like that i mean
that's how he i think got the idea to
put together kk's priest which would so
he's able to increase songs right
yeah and you know actually kk's priest
at kk's i forget the name of the the bar
uh slash
concert venue that he put together is it
the grind house or something like that i
i did find a set list and it's all
priest songs but then they just recently
did an album
and they've got
what was it like 10 or 11 tracks of
their own
and they're they're we'll talk about
that in a bit i think it's a good album
not a great album um but but i might be
wrong about that so rob says here's the
analogy let's say i found a non-profit
to help homeless kids and then decide to
leave and say all sorts of garbage about
everybody else involved
later on i decided i want to come back
do i have the right to it doesn't seem
so to me but are bands importantly
different in some way
so i mean i do think this goes to mark's
point um maybe some original members of
bands don't really
contribute that much
or they're they're left behind like paul
diano right so once you replace paul
diana with bruce dickinson the iron
maiden stuff that paul diana had a hand
in it it's changed you know bruce
dickinson singing running free is better
i would say objectively than paul diana
singing running free you know and it is
still identically
identifiably iron maiden
um some original members don't really
contribute that much i mean i would say
like some
are absolutely central so think about
thin lizzy
why
does the scott gorham
version of thin lizzy not produce new
music because it would be wrong to they
think there's an ethical argument to do
so after phil lynette who was so
absolutely central as both bassist and
singer and front man
and writer
died yeah yeah so that's like an extreme
case right
um
yeah it was thin lizzy was pretty much
phil
yeah
with with a backup band
i mean well i mean
when you've got gary moore playing for
you
gary morris
you know and and brian robertson and
scott gorham you know they're pretty
important
oh they're important i guess what i mean
is he was the face of the band yeah and
he had like you know john sykes is no
joke
one of the greatest
um
and i just think that but but nobody
really says like oh man i was a drummer
for thin lizzy and you're like oh
drumming for thin lizzy
yeah right i guess yeah um but that you
know that's one of those things the band
can't go on without phil yeah but i mean
they do and i think they're doing a
smart thing like you can't start writing
thin lizzy albums if you don't have
you know uh yeah
i mean
um
iron maiden without steve harris is it
iron maiden no
no not to me i don't think i don't think
they'd be selling tickets if he wasn't
in the bank and
you know he's one of the heavy writers
yeah so that's at one extreme right and
then we can say at another extreme we
have the people who
they're there but they're essentially
you know just kind of floating um
they're not making any major
contribution it's it's awesome that
they're there and it's fun but
they're not you know they're not really
doing something
distinctive and they could be replaced
and i i'm gonna say and scott correct me
if i'm wrong on this a lot of drummers
kind of fit that bill
fit the bill of replacement you could
you could replace them
uh i'm not saying all of them but but a
lot of them
i think there's there's like a greater
replaceability of drummers maybe than
there is for
like the key guitarist or well the the
drum the drumming and the time feel on a
rock band like for example there's no
way you could have replaced john bonham
okay yeah i mean he's one of the
greatest of all time and you know when
they came out and phil collins is a
great drummer but when they did live aid
with phil collins it just wasn't led
zeppelin
well
let's think of some great drummers like
so bill ward who is you know uh
yeah for what he does he's sort of like
um
um
clive burr
kind of jazzy there's there's a lot of
cool stuff going on
but you can replace in black sabbath um
bill ward with cozy powell because cozy
powell is good enough for that right
a great great great yeah i mean yeah but
but but it's gonna the sound's gonna
change though you know yeah yeah
like um what's up what's up i mean like
you know like i said phil collins is a
great drummer but was not john bonham
and i'm not saying who's better yeah um
well it's like well so maybe some of
these people fit into that like middle
third category so i was going to say
there's like the totally irreplaceable
there's the easily replaceable and then
you've got the people who are in the
middle
where they they do contribute something
is kk downing here's the key question
then is k.k downing somebody who
was absolutely irreplaceable for the
judas priest sound in their classic era
like if we took him away and replaced
him with richie faulkner uh you know
coming out of his his mom's womb
grabbing a guitar or something
or somebody else on the scene could
judah's priest have made the kind of
music that they did or is he more in the
middle section where he's making some
really solid contributions but he's he's
not generating something that gives him
like an automatic right to rejoin the
band
well that's such a good question i mean
for me it would come down to how much he
contributed in the writing because it's
not clear okay
it's not clear i mean if they're if
they're saying we did it that way so
it'd be fair we'd all get paid like you
know
the heads are going to roll riff at the
beginning um which guitarist wrote that
you know
if kk was the one that was writing all
those great riffs yeah
i think they they alternated back and
forth so let's say we credited him with
half of the great rifts you know
so he was part of the sound i'd say the
thing is as far as a player
um
easily replaceable as far as like uh
this the sound i mean okay
and i'm taking everything else off the
table it's just kind of like like let's
pretend that he got really sick and they
needed a guitar player to come in yeah
it wouldn't be hard to find somebody to
fill those gigs and although the
audience might want their money back
because
see people do go
to buy the ticket to see
maybe their favorite band member or
whatever it's yeah
so like you know it's like the when you
go to the plays the the lead role of
so-and-so will be uh played by the
understudy today oh no i came to see you
know
you know it's kind of funny with judas
priest um
i you know i love the band
i'm there to see ian hill
actually i actually wrote ian hill a fan
letter i don't write a lot of fan
letters
i wrote him a fan letter a couple years
back and sent it off i never got a
response
but he's he's such a you know i mean i
used to play bass um i'm always
listening for the bass going on yeah he
he made so many awesome contributions i
think he's kind of underrated as a bass
player you know he's not like steve
harris great
right but he's certainly he's certainly
uh
blackie lawless great you know maybe
beyond him um you know dave ellison uh
great you know
um
yeah
player yeah yeah yeah and he does some
really cool jazzy stuff on the earlier
albums and you know i mentioned the rage
um well actually yeah
his play was more linear earlier now
that you mention it linear i mean um
instead of just staying at the root note
maybe answering with a small phrase yeah
and that's the stuff that
people might not notice but if you took
it out of the song people go what
happened to the song you know it's like
one of those really makes the song in a
tasteful way i you know not till uh not
to you just said that did i really put
that together
because it was less of that later on
as they got heavier yeah yeah
but yeah there he's more sort of
following the riff and provide you know
doing you know going back to the root
note or stuff like that
oh yeah mark um oh sorry okay
so as a fan
i asked why downing once oops uh
rejoined the band spent so much time
training yeah well see the behavior
thing i i that's what i'm trying to get
at is
his behavior uh suggests that he doesn't
care about judas priest but rather his
own status
i'm gonna have to say that you know
to him there's no priest that isn't kk's
priest
no i don't think you're being harsh mark
i think this is a good point um but i
feel he already established his
influence on mental history that's right
why can't he be focused on the welfare
of the band that's that's a really good
point and the fact that i was i guess
you articulated better than me when i
was saying
if he stuck to his good points and
stopped the trash talking that
undermines the whole thing and i guess
mark what you're saying is
um he's
he's more concerned with making a name
for himself or his own status as you put
it i so so let's let's there were a
couple other ethical issues that i
wanted to
bring up here
um and i think this is a good segue into
that we i think we've talked enough
about whether he has a legitimate claim
that you know he ought to be
welcomed back maybe maybe there isn't a
a right or claim like that
and another one of the things that we've
touched on is how how should these
disagreements or demands be conducted by
those involved is there a classy way to
do this or you know is everybody
entitled to say whatever the hell they
want to because they're metal guys i
think we've talked enough about that
um one of the key issues that has come
up and actually there was a little bit
of a legal thing going on
is k.k downing entitled to use the
priest's name and i don't mean legally
entitled i mean
can he call can does it make sense for
him to talk about kk's priest that's the
that's the name of his band
um
he clearly thinks so right he clearly
thinks that he is
uh maybe the best representative of
judas priest
um
should he have called it something
different
what do you think
well in calling it keiki's priest he's
he's living off the priest's name
yeah um he could have started a new
project though
yeah like like halford with fight right
that's it exactly
um and
i mean they not that he put an album out
under the priest name right yeah
it could have been something else like
uh
um
when george lynch left he did lynch mom
right and there'd be a couple docking
tunes in the set but he played the lynch
pop stuff so it was he was going to go
out and write music why not
start his own project and then because
he was in priest throwing maybe four
classic songs of the set up that's what
halford did you know when alfred did his
solo you know it was just called halford
um
[Music]
yeah i mean did bruce dickinson do
maiden songs at all when he was off on
his own
or to dater and smith i mean i think
they'd be like the closest
correspondence you know
first i don't know if he did it wouldn't
surprise me if he you know threw three
in for the fans
yeah
but you know he had his own albums out
and he was when he toured he would do
the bruce dickinson at you know that's
that's how paul diano screwed himself
actually when he left iron maiden
uh well he didn't leave he was kicked
out
um he he was asked by you know the
concert promoters to do a couple iron
maiden songs he's like i'm not doing any
of that stuff i'm doing my own new stuff
you know
and
you know he didn't get any traction with
it unfortunately and if he had done
maiden stuff he probably would have come
out
a bit better you know dio always did on
stage some rainbow stuff some black
sabbath stuff
um
in addition to dio stuff so yeah he did
and you know
and the stuff that he did with the band
of course you know um
i always find it odd that when people
are
uh
like the band kansas when steve walsh
left
uh
uh john elefante joined and he put out
three records with them but now when he
does appearances he does songs he didn't
play on he does carry on my wayward son
that was steve wells he does all this
stuff that from kansas that he did not
that wasn't his songs
that's kind of strange but um
but i think maybe that shows a certain
kind of like easy goingness or
generosity to be able to
recognize you you know you talked about
the contract or not or not the contract
the relationship with fans
the fans do want to hear those old
standards right yeah
yeah
you know but like he had
big hits with kansas like play the game
tonight and fight fire with fire and
yeah and like i would imagine he would
want to do those but um yeah chris has a
really interesting point here that i
want to we'll come back to the the yes
personnel thing but he says kk is
classic judas priest i always picture
kk and tipton in my mind you think about
like these those posters we would get in
circus and put on our walls or something
so
i want to push this a little bit
um
i i think
chris is right kk is classic judas
priest he's not the judas priest of
firepower obviously
um
maybe
if you contributed enough to the classic
thing you get to use the
the concept or the name
right
um
may you know because the way that that
kk downing is positioning kk's priest is
it's it's like it's what judas priests
ought to have been it reminds me of uh
there's this band orchid in in doom
metal and one of the best things i've
ever seen written about them is they
play the songs that sabbath never wrote
you know so it's like
and i think it's a great descriptor of
this song
maybe maybe what k.k downing conceives
of himself as doing is
producing the songs that judas priest
should have made except in a you know
2022
or 2021 format you know with
the electronics and the new drumming
techniques and stuff like that
um
you know the other thing too is
with the priest's name i don't know if
you if you bring in other members who've
been in the band does that enhance your
ability to use that name
so like um
if you're um
[Music]
in this case we we've got tim ripper
owens and les binks who play with it so
three three members of a five piece band
are priest members affiliated yeah yeah
um
maybe that that raises it so like let's
say iron maiden
um adrian smith and um
[Music]
uh adrian smith leaves again and he's
like i'm gonna make adrian smith's iron
maiden and he gets blaze bailey to to
play with him and he can't get clive
burke because he's dead but right
who who else could he could he pick up
you know um i i don't know about the old
really old iron maiden members that
would be floating around out there um
right but you know if he got enough of
him
would he would he have legitimacy in
saying this is uh
adrian smith's iron maiden you know you
know now that you put it this way he
went on to do adrian smith and project
he didn't
to me
all these people that were comparing kk2
did not go
do a
another version of the band uh that they
left yeah um
[Music]
this is actually these are really kind
of strong points um
the more i think about it you know kkk
should just make a new band and fans of
priest would love it you know but now we
have this now we got to take sides and
you know i gotta i gotta talk which is
the real priest yeah yeah yeah right i
mean you know that's
that's that's tiring for the fans you
know um
right and and and mark so has a good
good point here as much as a jerk as
downing as being
i think artistically it's good that we
can experience both versions of these
bands downing has the opportunity to
make his iteration interesting
but i doubt he take it well i i do want
to say i've listened to um recently i
listened to kk downing uh
priest
what is the name of the the album um
he's got he's got this sermons of the
sinner
and i've only listened to it once and i
actually was texting scott back and
forth because i was listening to it at
the gym and i was like well
you know this this actually sounds more
like metal church than like priest you
know the first song uh but you know by
by the middle part i was like this is
good stuff it's not
great it's not like you're listening to
it you're like oh my god this is amazing
stuff right but it's not it's it's good
i won't even say it's not bad because it
is good and
there's you know
there's some good chops on it i'm i'm
kind of happy to
see that you know it's it's there um
i i would i would say
um
[Music]
you know listening to other people that
have left bands like herman frank has
put out a number of really great albums
recently herman frank of accept uh who
was treated really shabbily by um uh
wolf hoffman uh as is almost everybody
involved in excellent right that's right
and uh i would say that's better than
kk's priest but this is a very
subjective thing right when it comes to
newer classic metal stuff oh
chris chris
i saw that yeah
yeah
i mean there there are quite a few feuds
from these bands that were like really
like powerhouses in in the 70s right uh
and then made it made it into the 80s
um
i
guess pink floyd would be a massive one
right
yeah and
um this is all second hand but i have
i've had friends that worked on roger
water shows and stuff said he's got to
be the most
biggest prick
they just said you know
he even comes off that way on the dvd
that he did like 20 years ago and this
just shows him like yelling at everyone
like telling the sound guy he doesn't
know how to do his job and it's my way
of the highway
um so and you know
david gilmour seems like the sweetest
like laid-back kind of generous kind of
guy
and um
i'll have to follow that link
because i wonder if there's stuff that i
don't know in there
um
yeah one of the whole diva yeah that's
chris you're right and it's a great show
i mean jen kilminster is his guitarist i
think still
is dave kilmister still six times i know
dave a bit he's he's the guy from
england a really great guitar player and
um you know although he's you know he
didn't tell me
he didn't tell me anything especially
negative he just said it was kind of it
was you know it's uh you you got uh
you got paid for how hard you worked or
whatever's you know
um but i've heard people that have
worked the shows that are just kind of
like he was yelling at people you know
some kid that's supposed to have his
towel or something
radio chaos tour oh you saw that
oh man i do love that album
that's a good one chris
yeah he did you know he did great stuff
i think he's great
it's just that's the biggest feud when
they did what was it live eight together
they actually joined up and uh we all
thought well pig floyd's getting back
together no
and actually it's funny because roger
waters just talks smack like oh it was
david gilmour's you know uh
he really wanted to do it but i you know
um i just kind of ignored him and we did
it for a cause but you know i have no
interest in you know and he just shot
his mouth off but david gilmour didn't
say anything
yeah
but this is really uh it is of course
you know
if we think about pink floyd if they
were to get back together that would be
ideal although in the 80s they did they
did it without him and it was something
different like tony levin was playing
bass with you yeah yeah
i mean
this raises a question that we brought
up earlier if there is this much bad
blood between people can you actually
successfully bring them together put
aside the like they don't know the
catalog anymore they're you know maybe
out of shape or something like that i
mean and in this case
could
k.k downing actually work with a guy who
he thought was a clone of himself
could he work with
ian hill who he says you know stabbed
him in the back could he work with the
glenn tipton who he had all these
complaints about over all these years
i just don't see it happening and could
could roger waters really work with
david gilmour if you brought them back
together i i don't see that happening
you know no
i think david would be open to i don't
know i mean i have to read this this
link that chris put because there's
probably much more uh
i wouldn't
learn from it but you know you're right
i mean
look at chris
so basically what you're saying is that
kkk is scraped
that's basically what i'm saying yeah
yeah
so heads are going to roll we have
that's our second priest punt of the day
yeah we should probably work some more
in before before we had but you know if
you think about to go back to like
metallica and dave mustain i i've read
mustang's autobiography and his
autobiography is this is also something
i want to say about autobiographies
after this too mustaine's autobiography
is very unvarnished he's very clear
about where he screwed up and you know
what a jerk he was and stuff like that
he also you know paints a a very clear
picture of the metallica guys being
jerks too you know particularly james
hetfield and lars ulrich um
and you know he reconciled with them
eventually and he and he did do things
like where they would be in a tour
together or that that thing where they
all got up on stage and did diamond
heads am i evil where it was them and
and guys from slayer and guys from uh
anthrax right so he could cooperate with
them but you'd never see dave mustaine
saying i want back in metallica or
something like that
you know that's a good point
because well he
like we were just talking about before
he went out and started his own band
with his own music and why can't kk do
that
well he did effectively do that right i
mean he's just calling it kk's priest
well that's what i mean he's a he's a in
direct competition with the band he
wants to join
yeah well that's that's a good question
though
so i think you're right he is po he's
positioning at his competition
yeah maybe this is like mark was saying
you know maybe it's good to have these
two bands out there maybe it like
increases album sales and awareness for
both bands right so all of this
bullshitting around and making all these
complaints it's certainly bringing
priest and kk downing's priest
uh into you know all the the music
forums
um will this result in in
greater attendance at tours or better
sales of the priest album that they're
working on currently or the um
uh you know recent um
album
uh
that that uh here the sermons of the
sinner um
maybe
you know i
i don't know but um
yeah i mean the whole
you just put a great list about a minute
ago that i wanted to respond to you know
he can't work with this person this
person stabbed him in the back now now
i'm starting to ask myself why does he
want back in
right well i mean i can think of a
couple motives one would be that he
feels that he was
um treated badly embarrassed
you know maybe even humiliated and this
would be a way of overcoming that
um i and actually this is a great segue
so you know reading these two
autobiographies kk downing heavy duty
days and nights and judas priests and
rob halfords confess they both grew up
in the same
area in very similar environments and
they both spent a good bit of time
on their childhoods and it's it's quite
interesting to see
um kk downing had a shitty shitty
childhood you know
very clear you know um
just you know the first couple chapters
are about all the different things that
were happening and you know
disappointments and the family situation
that they were in
rob halford's childhood was not ideal
but
they go through some of the same stuff
and it's like totally different stuff
that totally different ways in which
it's it's it's happening uh to the to
the two
young young kids
in this this you know
industrial impoverished part of britain
and you know you actually kind of feel
as you're reading through it you feel
for kkk downing
not just as like oh well he had a bad
childhood and stuff like that you see
how this kind of trauma and deprivation
plays itself out in people's lives even
as they become adults and they try to
move past it and they they don't quite
get past it so you know maybe for
somebody like that
the
um feeling like your bandmates people
that that you know as richie faulkner
putting out you were connected with for
40 years are treating you as if you
don't matter
maybe that stings more than if you had a
a more stable background you know
yeah i mean
well
i mean uh
we i mean how old are they now they're
in their 60s
are they in their mid 60s uh i want to
say
either that or early 70s
yeah um
i because you know
you know as a matter of fact k.k downing
is in his 60s because i remember just
talking
with i think so but approaching 70 um
i remember talking with andy about this
a little bit before and comparing him to
like you know well my dad was born and
this year kk downing was born in that
year you know
oh gotcha
i just you know
you know we're born in 51 so he is he is
70.
oh he's born in 51 okay 70 right now
yeah
yeah i mean um
i guess what we're deciding is we don't
feel like kk's handling it in
in a great way i mean
um
[Music]
and you know the childhood i mean you
know rob
like you said had a tough childhood but
i don't see him acting like
kk about this right like i don't know
did he sling a lot of modded kk in his
book
no not that much
um as a matter of fact rob halford's
book is is a lot more centered around as
you would guess um
issues of sexual identity okay and you
know
i mean being
knowing that you're gay from from 10
years old
um
it is interesting because he does bring
up the fact that um this is kind of a
nice nice note to go out on his
bandmates were incredibly supportive of
that they never gave him a hard time
um and and you know if you think about
like even just when we were kids you
know growing up um the uh if you got get
viewed as being gay in the midwest and
you were you were a boy wow you'd get
your your butt kicked all the time and
stuff like that rob halford is growing
up in you know industrial uh england in
you know a much earlier time where
boy you could have gotten the crap
beaten out of you and he's going around
trying to hook up with guys while he's
on tour i mean he could have gotten
lots and lots of
problems and his you know
his his band well at least k.k downing
says we all knew he was gay there wasn't
any doubt about this you know we just
didn't talk about it you know and they
didn't talk about it not because it was
like oh terrible secret must hide under
the rug they're just like
we're not going to make an issue of this
because the the poor bastards already
got it hard enough you know yeah and i
think um
you know it it was probably extra
challenging being this kind of like
sort of macho metal front man you know
uh yeah you know is he gonna there's a
thought of am i letting my fans down
when it comes out
or um
but yeah so that's interesting i'll have
to actually read rob's book because
that's
i mean um i will say these these these
are both co-written books you know where
it's not it's not a ghostwriter it's
somebody who worked with with them right
they're both great autobiographies
um you get a lot of insight into
their characters um what was going on in
the band sort of complementary views of
things yeah i would love to see glenn
tipton or ian hill do a
book like this
to get to see what they think about
stuff would be quite quite cool yeah i
agree
yeah definitely
well before we go because i know we're a
bit over time and i i have a thing to do
at the top of the hour
any other ethical issues that we should
hash out or or
discuss i think we've actually covered
quite a lot of ground
in talking about this and managed not to
you know say well
jeremy bentham would say or emanuel khan
would say we've done it in a more more
grounded way i would say
yeah
and you know lots of good input
and suggestions and analogies
from our
interlocutors
uh
mark and and
chris and rob
but yeah anything else we should we
should hit on do you think or
that we've missed
well i think you know um
so wait well yeah should bands share
songwriting credits on all songs i mean
that's how van halen did it so there'd
never be a
money issue as a musician scott what do
you think about that idea
if i'm in a band yeah um
yeah i mean money becomes an issue in
those relationships you know bans
um
[Music]
you know people start to feel uh
unappreciated so it's you know like the
go-go's was like that's the
priceless one and they hated
what was it was it genus shock no
anyways they couldn't stand her because
they're like why is she rich and we
we're only making money off gigs and
they're like because there's this thing
called publishing she wrote all the
songs she makes the money
and
um you know they they're notorious for
hating each other by the next the second
tour they hated each other and um so i
think in a ban situation if you're gonna
be big especially back in the day
that that will definitely at least
take
the money issue off the table however if
there's somebody that's the main
songwriter
it's kind of like they're doing all the
work but everybody's getting paid the
same so it's like doing group projects
in in
high school right
one person would always do the whole
thing and nobody else would show up yeah
i used to hate those that's a good point
yeah
um
so
that's tricky um i've been in you know
i've been in songwriting situations
where i've co-written a song with the
with a songwriter
and then
okay we'll split this 50 50 and then
somebody will like make a oh you need to
change this one chord on the bridge i
want 25 of it and then the person took
25 of my 50 and they kept their 50. so
i'm like you mean i've written all the
music to this and one person changes one
chord and i'm getting as much as the
person that just changed one chord that
didn't need to be changed you know um
it's a touchy subject from
different points of view it's i don't
think it's an ideal way to to end you
know to
there's not a flawless way to do it but
if you do take money out of the equation
and everybody's getting paid
that
tends to be the most successful
so
mark has a
a good quip plato would say this is why
you lock the poets out of the city um
well that's the ideal city right
and we live in the non-ideal world
of uh all this craziness but i i think
it's important to hash these these
things out i i think a lot of the
discourse that we're finding about these
um
this issue
or connected issues in the forums is on
the one hand like poorly informed like
they're they only know one side of the
story and they're not really thinking it
out or it's kind of knee-jerk reaction
you know so i'm bringing some
some
philosophical reflection to it i think
is is quite helpful
yeah i mean and it's and it turns out
it's not really an easy
it's it is complicated uh yeah yeah i
think it comes down to
uh
um
kk it doesn't it comes a lot of it
doesn't just come down to if he has the
right to join the band it a lot of it
has to do with his behavior i think that
we've talked about
yeah about doing that and about
maybe we're questioning
what if if what he's doing is the right
thing to do you know instead of just
doing a solo project vis or starting a
new band
um like everybody else does
um
[Music]
and then of course you know not trash
talking
you know
why would you want to join a band of
everybody that stabbed you in the back
or
you know it wasn't a good experience
you're telling me
some people didn't even wait to like
quit a band to start trash talking think
about kevin dubra with quiet riot in the
1980s you know trashing motley crue and
van halen and rat and anybody else from
l.a as not being you know as great as
them to the point where like actually
fans would get ticked off about it in
the concert
so so there i guess there's a lot of
that in in metal but i don't know if
there's more of that in metal than in in
some other genres like maybe there's
more of it in metal than in soft rock
but
i don't know about you know metal versus
like
rap and hip hop on that or the jazz
scene or
um
maybe people are mean to each other or
disparaging uh
in any anything you can pick
yeah i mean with metal yeah you
outspoken i guess is the word
um and a lot of people think they're
gonna say something and they're gonna be
welcome with open arms and maybe they're
surprised that it didn't work out that
way you know you know uh making fun of
van halen it's not a good idea you know
yeah it's not good for business it's not
well
we get to make fun of van halen when
they become van hagar
but that wasn't what kevin dubrow was
complaining about at the time right
no i mean that was still when he was
i mean that was
80 around 1984 came out right kevin de
bruyne was outspoken early on i thought
yeah like
82 83 84. yeah
that yeah so um
yeah i just uh i don't like seeing that
stuff just as an artist i mean there's
people around town
that will do it to people uh
other players in the city or whatever um
but
you know to
like stuff getting put in print all the
time and now you know there's there's
always the risk is coming across as
primarily driven by resentment or envy
or some other negative emotion well
that's
yeah and it it could look petty or it
could look
that's a good word yeah
yeah it's just uh and i don't know like
what's the
do you do they feel they did kevin think
he was looking cool by saying that like
you know
um
you know there is something there is
something about like when you're angry
about stuff and you say disparaging
things about other people one of the
dangerous things about anger is it makes
us feel like we're so right you know
like we're in a groove
and you know so we say things and then
you know we think that we're like
expressing the best ideas in the world
and other people are like what is wrong
with this guy
yeah i think that's what happened with
kevin dubrow and maybe maybe that's
what's going on here with with our
interpretation of kk downing
who probably has a lot more
you know weight to what he's he's saying
in his complaints so
uh yeah so here's a great thing for us
to end on mark has uh
a good distinction we want loud heavy
metal not a loud bunch of whining
there's something
not
it's not very metal to wind is it
so no it's not
it's
so that's a great place to end uh thanks
to everybody for their their comments
and
conversation thanks again scott for
being here and oh it's always so much
fun
we'll see you all next time
see everyone
you